thor ragnarok had a pretty epic ending
with a nice setup for thor and the
revenge is going into Avengers infinity
war but recently the filmmakers revealed
some interesting alternate endings some
of which were filmed and others just
considered for the third-floor movie
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and today I'm talking endings we never
got to see crucial plot changes plus
another stack of deleted scenes rejected
concepts and end credits scenes that
have found out about since I made my
first video on thor ragnarok deleted
scenes don't forget I've still got some
cool Marvel merch to give away so make
sure you're a subscriber and comment for
your chance to win and obviously I'm
discussing spoilers so take care if you
haven't seen the movie yet in an
alternate post credits scene to the one
we saw in the film the grand master and
his right-hand woman topaz were going to
stow away on the ship with the
Asgardians at the end of the movie to
conceal their identity the dictatorial
geo would have put blankets over their
heads which really reminds me of the
scene where Thor does the same during
the Hulk parade and also at the moment
that scourge disguised himself with a
hooded cape and tried to stow away on
the ship leaving us guard that is until
he had an attack of conscience this
version of the end credits would have
left the Grand Master in a very
different situation to the final film
instead of still being on Sekar facing
his rebellious subjects this alternate
scene would have meant that just like me
as guardians he's traveling with the
grandmasters journey to earth would have
been interrupted by the arrival of
Thanos his craft to the sanctuary - it
would have been interesting to see these
two characters cross paths as their
comic book counterparts have done for
example when the Grandmaster lost his
mind gem to Thanos by the way the
grandmasters alternate post-credits
scene was actually filmed so hopefully
we'll get to see it on the DVD release
although the final movie sees as god
destroyed in an interview with empire
Taika Waititi revealed that the last act
of the movie could have been completely
different to what we saw on screen
indeed during early script development
as god wasn't going to be torn apart and
burned to bits instead it was actually
going to be saved from destruction
something I think many comic book fans
wouldn't have been especially happy to
see on screen given that Ragnarok is
supposed to be a cycle of death and
rebirth in the same interview ytt also
revealed that Valhalla was originally
going to be a significant part of the
film with a part of the journey actually
to Valhalla and a big showdown there I
wonder if that version of the script
would have involved Haller trying to
extend her domain from Hell to Valhalla
as she does in the comics hellas reveals
Odin's firstborn child was one of the
few secrets that was pretty well kept
until close to the movies release
however in early versions of the script
the reveal of hella as Thor sister
actually happened later in the story and
in the original draft it was Valkyrie
who told Thor that hella was his sister
when they were together in Hulk's suite
anza car in the final script though
Odin's dark secret that hallow was a
truer to the throne of Asgard was moved
earlier in order to avoid a possible
comparison with Star Wars The Empire
Strikes Back and the reveal of Luke
Skywalker's father at the end of that
movie and the person revealing that
information was changed to Odin as they
felt it made better use of Anthony
Hopkins limited screen time director
Taika Waititi also felt that hella being
a secret family member wasn't quite as
important as a dark truth it revealed
about how Odin had constructed a false
history about himself an Asgard which is
another reason why titi wanted to get
the sister reveal out of the way earlier
in the movie Hellas look and costume
also underwent several revisions and
there were some fascinating early
versions as well as this much darker
version of Haller and her costume her
headdress was also going to be
weaponized in an interview with Vanity
Fair VFX supervisor Jake Morrison
mentioned that an early design of
Hallows headgear included antlers that
could turn into face masks shields
almost like samurai style outfits I'm
guessing these might have been scrapped
because when producers have got
expensive famous actors for a big movie
they don't necessarily want them to
spend a lot of screen time with their
faces covered up while we didn't get
those extra features on Hellas costume
we still saw her in some pretty
fantastic action scenes that show off
her incredible power and the amazing
scene where Heller takes out the entire
elite Asgardian army single-handedly is
an extraordinary demonstration of her
capabilities but there are actually
multiple versions of this scene
originally it was meant to be even
longer but was cut back to avoid
repetition and extending production days
on top of that Jake Morrison explained
that it was actually filmed as a single
continuous action shot in which a
revolving camera tracked Heller as she
plowed through and killed everybody I
think a single camera
broken take of that scene could have
been amazing to watch however I can
imagine it would have been really
difficult to get just right and even
tiny errors in the Strunk choreography
or timing could have spoiled it
Martha has said that the scene was late
and re-edited to make it more percussive
which sounds like it perhaps wasn't
quite up to scratch to work as a single
shot and we also almost got a scene
between Heller and the destroyer the
Asgardian automate him from the first
Thor movie in the original draft when
Heller is looking for Heimdall sword so
she can operate the Bifrost bridge she
goes to look inside the weapons vault as
she enters the destroyer is activated
and tries to stop her but Heller just
rips it apart the scene was cursed as it
was mostly intended to be a callback to
the first movie and in the end felt
unnecessary by the way if you're a hella
fan who's hoping she somehow survived at
the end of the movie check out my new
Avengers infinity war theory video about
why I think there's a big chance we'll
see hella back in that movie speakings
Yahoo screenwriter Erik Pearson revealed
that when he came onto the project the
original writers had already included a
romantic relationship between Valkyrie
and Thor in the script personally I'm
happy that Pearson decided to scrap that
part of the plot and instead ensured
that Valkyrie had her own story rather
than just some romantic subplot and I
think it's much more interesting that
Valkyries story became more about the
mutual respect between her and Thor and
also dealing with her PTSD now I already
explained a lot of deleted scenes in my
previous video but since then there's
some new details come out about other
deleted scenes which I want to discuss
one especially great deleted scene that
I know many fans would have loved to see
was a callback to the Avengers in a
scene after the revenge is land on the
Rainbow Bridge there would have been a
moment where they stand for a second and
then help punches Loki right out of the
frame just like he did to thaw during
the Battle of New York in the Avengers
this would have been pretty funny to see
in the movie as Loki suspected he was in
trouble when he first saw Hulk in the
Grand Master's arena and this deleted
scene would have been even funnier
because during the arena scene Loki
himself cried out that yes that's how it
feels when Hulk smashed Thor around like
Eden to Loki in The Avengers
sadly ytt has said that the scene with
Loki getting punched out of frame was
cut for time that it might appear on the
DVD but I wonder whether as part of
the missing scenes on the Rainbow Bridge
that we never got to see like their
Avengers lining up to face off against
Heller plus various hella fight moves
there was another funny scene in the
trailers of banner and Thor talking
about muscles and brains that sadly
didn't make it in my biggest muscle in
the body I've got lots of muscles so
technically more brains the joke would
been especially sweet since it was a
callback to Thor's mockumentary video
with darrell where he makes a similar
joke this is knowledge knowledge is
power no it's not knowledge is not power
that's power the brain is a muscle and
that's a muscle and that's a muscle
there you're all muscles this is all
muscle so I am covered in brains and I
have more brains than you
Saturn Thor were also together and yes
another humorous but slightly gross
noodle worm scene that ended up Kurt
according to screenwriter Erik Pearson's
interview with Yahoo there was an
emotional check-in moment with Bruce
Banner and Thor before the finale with
banner eating alien food and trying to
be serious it looks like spaghetti but
then he realizes a thing he's eating is
alive despite multiple rewrites of what
Pearson called a pivotal character
moment the scene ended up being canned
as it crushed the momentum of the movie
now it was already a deleted snippet
from Valkyries flashback scene that we
saw teased in the trailers of Heller
turning nonchalantly to the camera but
there was another moment missing from
the flashback that looks like it could
have explained exactly how Valkyrie
survived the massacre the Valkyrie or at
the hands of Heller the FX studio rising
some pictures he worked on the flashback
scene revealed that the reason Valkyrie
survived is it she fell into a portal
and escaped
you do see Valkyrie falling back at the
very end of the flashback but there's no
obvious portal behind her which makes me
think the scene was cursed a little
short and I wonder whether it was going
through this portal that meant she ended
up on Sekar something which I've been
asked about is why Thor has both eyes in
the trailer when in the movie he loses
one to Heller
plus if you've seen the infinity war
footage from d23 and comic-con he'll
know that Thor had both his eyes intact
there too the simple answer is that
Marvel wanted to avoid spoiling the fact
that Thor loses his eye a plot point
that comes near the end of the film so
they made sure he appeared with both
eyes in the marketing materials for
Ragnarok and infinity war
Thor losing his I was always in the
original story and ytt has talked about
it being part of stripping down thoughts
character starting with the loss of his
father than his hammer his eye and
finally his homeland Asgard the eyepatch
that Thor puts on at the end is a
symbolic reference to his father Odin as
well as a nod to the comics and Chris
Hemsworth has confirmed that this is the
look we'll see for Thor in Avengers
infinity war so did you like the way
that thor ragnarok ended and would you
like to have seen any of the deleted
scenes included in the movie be sure to
leave me a comment below with your
thoughts and also subscribe for a chance
to win a Marvel Funko pop or an obsessed
with Marvel buh-bye Titan books if you
haven't already seen my first video tap
the screen here to check out more Thor
Ragnarok deleted scenes or why not watch
my Hallett and Thanos Avengers infinity
war theory thanks for watching and see
you next time
you became movie lovers